hello today I want to touch on a very
thorny subject as far as language
learning is concerned and that is
grammar um some people believe that
grammar based approach is key to
efficiently learn a language they think
that a thorough study through grammar
study is necessary for understanding the
structure of the language they insist
that without grammar without grammar
books it would be impossible to decipher
the language itself and the language
would just be a jumble of words and a
comprehensible jumble of words so some
go as far as to say that you need to
learn grammar even before tackling the
language itself I call this this
approach a purely analytical approach on
the other hand there exists another
school of thought which I call the
purely deductive approach according to
which grammar books especially at the
beginning are is just a unnecessary
obstacle plain it just slows down
literally slows down language learning
because all you have to do as far as
learning a language is concerned is just
attack the language directly so here the
key words aren't massive exposure and
deduction the art of deduction now I
wanted to share with you my personal
vision on this topic and I just wanted
to start by quoting afraid here that I
found on the internet and I'm going to
read and here it says grammar is the
structural foundation of our ability to
express ourselves the more we are aware
of how it works the more we can monitor
the meaning and effectiveness of the way
we and others use the language it can
foster precision detect ambiguity and
exploit the rich
of expression this can help anyone not
only language teachers but all teachers
of everything was what was struck me
here was the phrase the more we are
aware of how it works well you know what
I don't think we need to be aware of how
it works that's a problem we just have
to make it work I think that once once
we're able to speak a language to make
it flow and one once a language is
accurately expressed you have a
internalized grammar unconsciously now
five-year-old kids for example are not
even conscious of the concept of a
grammar but they do speak the language
fluently
um I think that as far as school the
school system is concerned they propose
a very inefficient approach the problem
in general with adults but this is
humanity I think that in some issues
there is a tendency to categorize the
world now for example as far as purely
scholastic subjects if we consider
purely scholastic subjects like
geography like history for example or
modern biology history philosophy etc um
dividing them dividing material into
into smaller categories can actually
help you understand them better because
you divide them you categorize them and
then you can into smaller modules
smaller unities that can actually help
but the problem here is that language
learning learning how to speak a
language is an ability that we acquire
over time via trial and error by trying
and failing and try it again and
exposing ourselves to language it is not
a subject to study but it is an ability
to learn and the problem is that
languages are treated like other
subjects in school and that's that's I
think as far as I'm concerned that's my
humble opinion that's the the biggest
mistake
that education tutors make not all of
them but some of them and the system is
conceived this way what do you think is
that grammar can be a very interesting
field for grammarians and linguists it's
undisputable without a doubt it's a very
interesting field but from the
perspective of a language learner the
goal is to speak the language not study
it that's that's the main problem we
want to make it flow like kids do now in
this regard obsessing with grammar
you know everybody's conscious of
grammar verb verb tables of vocabulary
pronunciation dividing fragmenting the
language entities categories is as far
as I'm concerned a very inefficient
approach our final goal is how to
efficiently get across ideas to other
human beings and that's what's all about
what it's all about that's the problems
we have to consider the language as a
unique block not divided into grammar
tables etc etc furthermore students are
given a marks for their performance
performance I call it performance that's
a problems that language learning is not
purpose it's not about performing is
about communicating and the problem is
if we if you have this mentality of
having to perform a little time you will
be stressed and stressful and and stress
is one of the worst enemies that you
pose that you might stumble upon in your
linguistic path that's the main problem
so now um I think that the the easier
and the the more simple the more
counterintuitive the the more consistent
a method where an approach is the more
efficient it is so what I think is that
for example interesting content is
absolutely key I don't understand why in
school we have all these books that are
absolutely boring I just saw how I had
to remember having my books and were
terrible and I just took a look at
recently a couple of months ago at the
books that a kid had I was tutoring was
a total disaster interesting key and
especially in the Internet era you can
find so much interesting content on the
Internet interesting interesting
material is key because it motivates a
student to understand if you take a look
you'll grab get hold of very interesting
text you want to you want to understand
what it means you will be motivated to
analyze it to understand it to highlight
words you know try to understand the
meaning of a sentence which is a little
bit of secure and that that is the will
to connect with the language and I think
that you have to do it a lot reading and
listening to a lot of interesting
material is key so if in language in
school for example your teacher gives
you very interesting material and you
the teachers on your side so he's
explaining the obscure points he's
trying to point out the things in game
in grammar as well as as well as in
pronunciation you learn a language
without even mentioning the word grammar
he doesn't need to say disss grammar he
just needs to say this is this would
this works this way this rule works this
way so what I think is that you should
we everybody should stop analyzing and
start learning stop thinking and start
enjoying these are the key factors now
breaking the code I consider languages I
view languages as codes it means that
for example when you break the code you
have figured out the pattern or the
patterns underpinning underlying of the
code itself how to break the code that's
that's that's the main problem how to
break the code without using or using in
this case manuals or grammar tomes etc
how to put all this how to put all this
into practice into a method I'll give
you a I'll give you an example which is
a very simple example it doesn't have
anything to do with languages but has
with cognitive learning let's suppose
that I'm going to give you to give you
these numbers it's 0 1 1 2 3 5 8 13 etc
now instead of telling you exactly what
it's all about I'm going to give you a
hint I'm going to tell you that there is
a pattern here it's a rather simple
pattern so she you should you should
actually figure it out it's something
that has to do with a connection to
adjacent or two consecutive numbers have
a relationship with the third number
with a father with a number following
those now stop the video for a second
try to think about it and try to figure
it out okay have you found the solution
if you have found the solution it was
easy right it was not that difficult now
the fact that you have found that you
have discovered this precise and single
pattern in terms of cognitive learning
it means that you have a by figuring out
this pattern it calls it as figuring out
the spot a pattern causes a neural
network to to form new connections
neural connections to form and it is
quite important let's imagine that hat
told you directly that this is called
the Fibonacci series and I'm going to
quote it here that's the definition
mathematical definition the first two
numbers in the Fibonacci sequence are 0
and 1 in each subsequent number is the
sum of the previous two okay you it's
just
FN equals FN minus 1 plus FN minus 2
fault if I had given you this definition
immediately you might have I I would
have given you the information this
notion you have been told how it works
but it's better to figure out how it
works and once you figure it out once
you figure out how it works and then I
tell you
it works it reinforces even more the
concept you've learned something you
haven't been told something this is a
mathematical example but it applies to
language learning too if you have a
sentence for example or in Japanese
let's suppose that you're dealing with a
very difficult layman finger if your
firm your native one for example you're
Italian you're American you're trying to
figure out a japanese sentence and it's
uh it's very long and this works exactly
is what you're trying to figure out
something and what if if you have
grammar notes on the side that explained
to you to explain to you what it means
then you will connect you will connect
the dots you will close the cognitive
the cognitive pattern as a the cognitive
circle as I call it and it's a much much
more efficient method than just having
things explained that for example
somebody explains to you all the time
how bright how something works you will
learn it of course but you will not
learn and as efficiently as if you were
trying to figure it out by yourself now
how to put all this into practice I have
a very precise techniques for this
especially as far as grammar is
concerned and I will share them with you
on my blog the you know polygon the
polygon cream.i you will find the you
can find in the box below the the link
to the article of the blog and will just
follow me and I'll try to not to teach
you but I will try to show you what I do
and you can do the same and you can
learn grammar without even mentioning
the word grammar thank you very much